[Music]
hello everyone this is one of the
Masters of an employer and I'm here at
the San Luis chess club
for a new lesson with you today's lesson
is going to be prepared like a pro and I
have checked a little bit how other
players who who are teaching this this
lesson specifically Grandmasters who are
teaching this lesson how how they
emphasize on on it but I always like to
make my own touch on on each class and
kind of try to bring something a little
bit different not too much from the
original because obviously you know
there's gonna be something uh related to
the theme but usually what I've noticed
is that Grandmasters do show you the
entire process through which they go
um go on to prepare for a game so
usually you know they study their
opponents or first and then they use
engines for Preparation they analyze
openings and things like that so what I
want to do today is actually a little
bit different so I chose this topic of
knowing your you know various ideas on
the Sicilian so that you don't fall for
specific traps that's something else
that's important in the preparation when
you're learning uh an opening or you're
trying to improve upon an opening uh you
don't want to just memorize moves right
you want to try to understand what's
happening in those
um
why those moves are being played you
want to understand
um
the history of it how it came about why
is it that those moves are the ones that
are important and so on
so today is also a very special day and
I know this is going to be a YouTube
tube but it's a special day here it's
March 9th 2023 and that's
the reason they say special is because
Bobby Fischer would have turned 80. and
for me growing up in my family we were
studying a lot of fishers games my dad
was a huge fan and so I couldn't
start the day without or the class
without talking about him so I chose
this game that he played a bit against
Robert Eugene Byrne so we'll start with
so Eugene so burn had the white pieces
and Fisher had the black pieces and they
played this game in
um
in this inter-zone tournament I believe
it was 67. so in 1967
in Susan
walking into peoples of beat opening
prep traps is the primary reason I don't
play the Sicilian okay but listen um
it's not just so you you want to try to
learn uh you want to try to learn the
ideas for every single opening that
you're playing don't just learn the
moves try to understand the ideas behind
it and
and um
I also think it's important that you
study the classics
of course opening theory is becoming
more and more important these days so
you do have to stay up to date with what
is happening but knowing some classical
games is also very important so we're
going to get started with this game and
see how Fisher ended up totally crushing
his opponent in this game so it's
because of some Sicilian themes that
white wasn't so familiar with or so we
say so burn started with E4
C5
Knight F3
D6
d4c takes D4 Knight takes D4 Knight F6
Knight C3 and now the move A6 what's the
name of this opening well it's the
naidorf
always carry on E6
hi everyone by the way if you're if
you're watching right now live just want
to say hi welcome hope you're having a
wonderful evening if you're gonna watch
this YouTube later well
thanks for being here hope you enjoyed
this video
yes the Knight or Fisher played the
Knight dwarf so the point is here that
you want to go for E5
and recently I've been kind of
interested in studying new openings I
wasn't doing that very much but I
thought listen
kids these days know a lot of things and
they have time to spend to memorize
openings why wouldn't I
well
because when you're an adult you might
not have as much time to do it but it is
very important to find time to study new
things and naidorf has been one of these
things that
um
you know I think it's
it's very popular so it's an opening you
want to kind of become familiar with a
little bit okay
um so Asics Bishop C4 this is called the
soldzing and for today I kind of focused
um I have various games we'll see how
many we can go through
that are in the southern
for the night of right like I said you
want to potentially go E5 but there are
a couple of moves that white can play in
this position where you don't go E5
that's something I learned the hard way
when I was testing out the night off
myself by playing some Blaze online and
those moves that I've come up with so
far are Bishop G4 sorry Bishop G5 and
Bishop C4 those are two moves where you
will not
where where you will not play
um
uh E5 yes I know according to leeches
it's not called the sauzin I also knew
that the sauce in uh Sicilian was
actually against the dragon but
I call it the sauce in so I hope you
give me you know
um
the option to say that hi
all right
playing Bobby's move against him bold
strategy let's see if it pays off let's
see all right so yes leeches does call
this the lipnet scheme all right so
Bishop C4 E6 all right
Bishop B3 it is important for white to
make this move because
um there are some situations where black
is going to develop with Tempo and
sometimes they're also falling for this
kind of little trap that you might want
to know if you're going to study
openings you want to to study various
tactical ideas that are present in the
opening so here Bishop B3 was played and
Fisher played B5
and now if you're on Lee chess and you
check this position is going to tell you
that it's the sauzin attack so I was
right from the first from the get-go
just to be clear all right so these days
people I think are going for Castle
but burn went for F4 very aggressive I
think this move these days maybe or this
this whole entire idea is that when you
have the bishop in B3 it's locked by
these two pawns so you're trying to
think of a way to mess up that pawn
structure so this is the way to do it
and if you are one of those people that
likes to listen to maybe say uh Ben
Feingold who tells you never to push the
F Pawn well
this move maybe he might be right this
time like totally never do it
um not a hundred percent though but
um it is an idea that that white plays
often against the Sicilian many
Sicilians but typically you do it after
you Castle but you can change it a
little bit so F4
um and Bishop B7 you have to be a little
bit careful with the development with
black
by the way hi everyone
um I might not get the chance to say
hello to everyone thanks for being here
hi everyone who's who's joined the
classroom here as well
thanks for coming hopefully you'll enjoy
the class it's a little bit different
than what would typically be taught by a
Grandmaster when you are at the prepare
like a pro because you know
um I had to put my
my own ideas into creative ideas and I
have to say I'm not the best at at
preparation at opening preparation I
usually ask my coach
um I I often you know ask my coach to
to teach me to to tell me what is best
that in my opponents do this do that you
know so unfortunately I kind of
messed up on that part so I'm trying to
learn to do it myself these days we'll
see how it works
but an idea that's important with the
bishop and the Knight there is there
could be sacrifices so you have to be
mindful
on how you get these two pieces out
because if you're not careful there
could be Bishop takes
Pawn takes and then Knight takes E6 and
then your queen is going to be in
trouble and then this Pawn is going to
be hanging so you have to be mindful of
how you develop definitely don't trap
your queen that's an idea that I learned
as early as six years old
so
I still remember it that surprisingly
very surprisingly anyways so Bishop B7
and here burned made
the move F5
which I believe this entire idea is not
as great for white
and you'll see why because I have
the game to prove
so what do you think Fisher played in
this position this Pawn is being
attacked
what is the whole strategy of white is
trying to get you to push the pawn
forward so that they get to open up
their Bishop from B3 and get that
Outpost which they normally would have
gotten if they didn't play Bishop C4
black would have gladly played D5
immediately but uh but this way white
thinks that with the spawn in F5 is
going to be more dangerous because they
all have ideas with pinning that night
and then maybe in some situations there
could be some tactical idea with Knight
E6 or something like that
Bishop E7 no it's not Bishop B7 no are
you just joking are you trying to what
about people here in the classroom
people in the chat are saying strange
things at the moment I think they're
just trying to troll me a little bit but
how about people in class what would you
play with black in this position would
you say you know what burn I don't care
about your F5 I'm gonna go E5 anyways
D5 okay that's
quite an interesting approach that's not
a good one however no Patrick no
what about here in the class
anyone is willing to
share their thoughts of what they would
do you might not be playing this opening
but it's nice to study the classics to
kind of
learn various things who knows maybe
you'll just
love some kind of opening
and then you will get on studying it and
then start crushing some opponents
that's the goal right so in order to get
yourself motivated to play an opening
what you need to do is just study some
Classics that totally crushed everyone
in that opening that way your your
motivation to play that will be very
high because you'll be like Oh I'm gonna
you know that's good then you just need
to make sure you're you're good enough
to
calm yourself down if you start losing
and just be like you know it's fine I'm
gonna learn the reason why I messed up
and then come back
about
on to
actually
before
that's an interesting thing but he has a
threat so you have to calculate if he
takes here and takes here
there may be some issue for you
in the position
yeah I'm teaching I'm teaching how to
Swindle your opponents for sure
um so then we take here right
I'm not quite sure where you move your
king and then I would have a check as
well if you go to D7
if you go to E7 I might have this check
your king will stay in the center and
you'll struggle with the development so
the piece that white sacrifice will
totally pay off there's also Bishop A4
check that's very unpleasant
um
and uh
I would not be comfortable to play this
maybe you would be would you be
comfortable with decking you will be
before if you go back yeah
he pushes
um
he took you said before he white tips
well I can take back with a knight and
then your queen is attacked and then I
also have again that check and depending
on where you move the queen I just won a
pawn and then I keep going
I'll move my knight off or you think
you'll take this Pawn Yeah
yeah okay where did you move the queen
if you do this for example I think I
will just come here or something
and then if you take
something like that
the the funny thing about this line is
that
this is a move too
it looks quite bad I oh oh wait wait I
give you check and then if you go here I
might give you this check Discovery and
then bam
it's looking so
Sicilians oftentimes are quite tactical
but you have to be mindful about your
king quite a lot I would say so he did
go for E5 here
that pawn was attacked so he went for it
and this idea this is something that I
wanted to emphasize on today because
there have been various games played in
different years so this one is in 67 and
I have a couple of others will see like
I said on how many we have time to go
over today but we will
we will look at these ideas that white
things are supposed to be good for them
but they might be good in some Sicilians
but not in the night or they don't turn
out to be very good now this Knight has
to go back so burn went back to E2 and
Fisher just proceeded with finishing his
development 97.
94. someone said 94 yeah not 94. you
also didn't want to take there like
allowing the capture here with a pawn of
white it's not gonna be very good for
you
okay so why it continues their
development as you notice white has not
castled yet but the reason they can hold
off to the castling is that the center
is somewhat blocked so you're not you
know super worried about it so Bishop G5
Bishop E7
now
I just want to go back for a couple of
most to kind of show you how that line
would normally go with the bishop G5
because this is what you would get this
is what you would what people normally
do so they go F4 and then Bishop E7 and
then white sometimes just takes their
Queen out here and this is a move that
every single time I end up playing
Knight or phone line although I have
spent a little bit of time studying it I
forget
so you have to understand the ideas to
remember specific moves the move that I
forget that is very important if you're
gonna play with black pieces is Queen to
C7 why to stop the bishop to go there
because it's going to be annoying
but this is a little bit different for
white and white typically ends up
castling long and at some point they do
play there but
black is having you know pretty decent
position I keep forgetting to play this
move so if you're setting this make sure
you remember to play this if you play a
move like B5 which is a move that I
sometimes play uh you're gonna lose
uh Knight C6 is something else that I
play because I keep forgetting and then
they Castle or they take and I still end
up having kind of a slightly worse
position so the move for black in that
position is Queen to C7 but let's go
back to our actual game of Fisher so he
closed down the position Bishop G5
Bishop E7
and here White Plain Knight to G3
oh the game you're gonna show me was
this line where you had to show it I
don't know why you didn't want to show
it just Bonzo you had to
all right
does anyone hear in classes any
questions so far
nope okay
so Knight G3
and very soon we're gonna see a very
typical idea for the Sicilian does
anyone know any typical ideas in the
Sicilian
that black can do
no
I'm just giving you I'm just giving you
the hint right now for a little bit
later when it will actually be very
important this is a very typical
exchange sacrifice that black ends up
doing in a lot of Sicilians so you
sacrifice The Rook for that night they
usually recapture and you're getting rid
of a protector of this Central Pawn
only Stack The Exchange they say in the
chat
sometimes yes this is super typical so
this is what one of the reasons why
white brings the Knight to G3 to keep
that pawn protected and maybe in some
situations they could maybe I guess give
up the bishop pair and then get the
Knight to attack but they also want to
protect so that this Knight could move
and not be bothered by potential
sacrifices or sometimes before
just keep that in mind it will happen
eventually burn went for the development
um here Castle
and now it's time to see a gorgeous move
that Fisher played in this position
if
to protective super tech typical says
someone in the chat
if you're gonna give me words like that
just get ready that I won't be able to
pronounce them correctly
okay so let's see Queen no Queen no
queen move we have almost completed our
development with black so
now if you're thinking to Castle here
you would be wrong because white has
already given himself quite some Edge by
pushing the pawn in F5 so his pieces
would come for the attack very easily
so there could be some captures here
night coming to H5 Queen coming to G4
and white could could start attacking
you so you would not want to Castle here
right now
um you could consider taking your queen
out and you could just give this check
as if you can develop your pieces with
Tempo you should do that so there's this
check that you could give
but then what would be your plan how
would you continue things because yes
you have given yourself a little bit
more space here but I don't believe
you're ready for this exchange sacrifice
just yet
so Fisher came up with this really
really cool idea I don't know if someone
had played it before him or not
I see some people in the chat do know
what the idea is maybe some of you are
playing the naidorf anyone here in the
classroom that would like to take a
guess as to how Fisher started this is
an attacking game obviously I try to to
choose not some boring positional chess
you know since we're talking about him
we run some attack so let's see some
attacking idea who can come up with an
attacking idea
Queen check yeah so that was an option I
as I said that there was an option he
did not play that one though
Pawn H6 here
uh close but no
more aggressive go more address more
aggressive than that
more aggressive which one of Black's
pieces is not into play besides the
queen which will get to B6 eventually
potentially
there's another piece of of blacks that
does not do much
which one
that this one yes so let's get that drug
into play
so
yeah I was thinking about that but
there's more
um going from Brook uh pushing the pawn
all the way up here yes yes that's what
Fisher played good job yes
princess
I know it's scary but listen listen is
good the engine approves to the engine
approves
um it's there have been other games that
I want to show you with a similar idea
that's why I'm saying Classics are
important and actually I'm
um yeah so bring in bring in the
artillery the side of the board the
reason you can do that this part of the
board is blocked right now you can't do
much yes D5 is a typical idea for some
Sicilians but right now you're not
really quite ready to do it you've got
still looking in the center and they
have way more attackers than you have
Defenders for that specific Pawn so I
think
you don't want to give it up just like
that you usually want to you have
something in return and here they would
just take the Free Pawn
so H5
and it is very unpleasant in some
openings this idea happens and then
white ends up going Knight H1 Knight F2
and then brings the Knight back into
play but right now H4 is a real threat
because if the snipe goes away then the
spawn is going to be hanging right so
now I'm thinking
the Knight
here
for white or for black
but it's way to move right now it's
white yeah yeah so black wants to play
H4
a white stopped him by playing H for
himself
did you say good
good okay that's unpleasant you don't
want that night again
night here
So eventually yes you want to do that
but
um first
you know we wanted that pawn didn't we
the queen Jack
but you know you want to play this but
you already lost the piece so I can sack
my exchange back you know right
so if you do that this is your thinking
processor okay
you don't get it I think you're gonna
get mated before you get that night
I don't know how but uh let's think
I do I don't know exactly how I'm I'm
thinking
um there should be some way because like
if I get this pawn and then I go maybe
here I should be able to to have a mate
like maybe I just go here first
but then maybe you have F6
then maybe I just take I just take here
yeah
we'll take
it
you're really not scared
okay I can see that okay okay there's a
mate
there's supposedly a mate here let's
find it
it's it's all with check
all with checks
check check
white why to move now
a check
look on the entire board don't don't
stay focused just here you would
separate the queen no not the queen
the bishop
check you gotta take then then we got
three pieces we have more than enough to
mate yeah
yeah
okay let's see where do we discuss do a
discovery with this bishop
well what pawn do you want to take
no we move this bishop somewhere and
then we check my dare so we're doing
move it so that he cannot Escape
the
other side it will be
made in a few more moves because he goes
to f8 and then when you check him here
he's gonna run away that way so if you
do here he can go there has to go there
and then you meet him here
so it's a little bit like this is so you
have to be mindful how many pieces
you're going to take from your opponent
when you have the king in the center you
should not be greedy
because because they can they can just
sacrifice a few and then if they have
they only need technically two pieces to
mate you right one is usually not enough
so if they have two pieces it's just
not going to be you know
okay so Knight G4 this is a nice idea
though like well well thought of for you
so this is definitely an idea that I
feel like you have caught some people
with this idea haven't you
yeah okay I see I see well now they're
here in class now they see their maybe
you have to be mindful how much you're
sharing you know you know now they will
not fall for it they pay close attention
you know like
um anyways
so in this position
um H4 yeah
anyways yes if you're a computer it's
easier to to come up with things for
sure
um but anyway so B4
Bishop takes F6
was played
he took with the bishop yes this is
quite typical and now he's giving this
Pawn up but you cannot take this Pawn
because
what was the thread before what was
Black's threat before
no
but you need to remember you need to
remember so when you're playing you know
this is part of part of your preparation
too when you're training at home like
when you're training specific things and
you want to improve your calculation it
is very important that you don't forget
that there could be in between moves at
some point that are being played and you
shouldn't forget what your threat was
before those in between moves happened
right so when when B4 so after h
when this move was played this was the
threat right yeah so that was the threat
so now although this happened and we
took back you know this was an
in-between move a capture but then
uh
and then
um
yeah
yes that was the thing yeah
all right so let's go back here to 95.
all right so Bishop takes here
was played by Fisher
and uh now we gotta figure out what
we're gonna do with white because they
wanted a Fisher wants to take the Knight
so what are some ways that we can do to
to uh to protect the Knight here
hmm you want to play here
but then we'll continue the attack
I believe I hope that's what Fisher was
thinking maybe he wasn't thinking that
this seems like a thing to do maybe you
could go Queen here but then we would
attack you Knight C5 and go for that
pawn you know
so
[Music]
um
takes
and this I think this is so beautiful
because you know he pushed the H4 the H
Pawn to try to chase that Knight away
but now the age file opened up and now
it makes total sense why Fisher did not
Castle because he can utilize this Rook
so much better basically after white
captured here this Rook is technically
opened this technically has been
developed it's perfectly ready for the
attack and he didn't even need to do a
thing
so now after Knight H5 Queen G5 oops
Queen G5 was played tempo
go back night where are you gonna go
oops that Knight is trapped
so he ended up playing F6
in this position because he's trying to
get his Knight
to G7 and then maybe have some ideas
with the fact that black skin is still
in the center
but you see how this remained blocked
and now with the knight in D5 although a
great piece this is an outpost that's
typically what you want to do with the
Knight but usually you want the queen to
go there
um and and try to mate if you could like
if he if black took the Knight and queen
took oh that would be really bad but
right now it looks really nice but it
doesn't really do so much I would say
so only move for Fisher was G6 and after
Knight G7 check King d8 you could get
scared if you were to play with black in
this position you could get scared
because you would say oh my God my king
is in the center I'm not going to Castle
anymore in fact I'm staying on some mate
if my opponent can get a queen here it
would be a mate what am I gonna do I'm
gonna lose this game
but no because actually Black's King is
much safer here than white skin and if
Bishop G3 is played this is a very
typical idea of mate that I feel many of
you who have done tactics I've seen
have you seen this where you sacrifice a
queen and then
yeah yeah okay good so
what
why
well if you see it don't do it unless
you see it obviously you should see it
first
like make sure it's made you don't want
to just sacrifice or are you gonna
Swindle your opponents yeah
no no so like for example let's just
make some bad moves for right just two
waiting moves here for right
so that you see this idea yeah sacrifice
The Rook right sir Rook yeah you give up
The Rook he takes then you give this
check
and then you give this mate absolutely
yeah so that's in case you know white
just does nothing for two moves that's a
very important idea that you probably
have seen somewhere might not be super
typical for the Sicilian that specific
one for the Sicilian is this this uh
this sacrifice but now there's this H5
H4 that we just learned that it's super
super extra interesting that you can do
when White Castle is there so anyways
Rook here was played
um Bishop G3
and Fisher is going basically for the
same idea just blocking The Rook
uh burn is like oh my goodness let me
get rid of that Bishop
what to do can we did he actually defend
the mate
can we go Rook H1 or not is the question
no it's not mate he escapes
here here check here what do you do
take the Rook
I'm not sure take the pawn okay you take
the pawn sure but I feel that here
white is going to be so excited because
after this move I think I'm just putting
my queen in front and then
how much extra material do I have I have
like a rook right a look for a pawn
or do you see a mate
the attack is over what does this teach
us
that we haven't prepared like a pro just
to use that terminology now that we have
not calculated correctly so when you
make a sacrifice when you give up
something as valuable as The Rook you
need to have to make sure it's gonna
lead to a mate
otherwise you just you know if you
cannot calculate all the way till the
end and you feel that you don't have
sufficient pieces just try to to
consider the pieces I know it's hard
sometimes to calculate too many moves
ahead but try at least to kind of think
about how many pieces you have left that
are attacking and how many pieces your
opponent have around the king that are
protecting and if it's about the same or
if they have more then you're probably
not it's not okay to uh to to sacrifice
someone in the chat says first you
sacrifice then you calculate no no you
first calculate you first calculate so
Fisher played this move Bishop H2 check
and white now has to go here
why does white have to go there why
couldn't they go here
Discovery where because then he goes
back to G1
hi everyone new in the chat by the way
anyone has any ideas
on how we can
do things here I think
I think it's Bishop here check I believe
but I could be totally wrong because
um because now I'm thinking he could go
Rook H3 and uh
and then I'm not sure anymore
myself maybe I should have
but okay we have Rook H4 but I don't I
don't know
I don't know 100 of this would work
you know we don't need to rush that's
that's quite unpleasant for him in this
position maybe we can go Knight C5 first
but the bishop was in G3 someone was
saying Bishop G3 the bishop was in G3
this was the position where Fisher
played Bishop H2 I'm pretty sure he did
not want to make a draw I can tell for
sure this was played in the I think it
was a candidates tournament in Susa
Algeria I believe
so King F1 was played
I think Knight C5 is good we we can we
can check with the engine there for a
second to make sure yeah it seems like
it's good
Bishop takes D5 is another option that
is suggested but I like Knight C5 it's
more human to chase this queen away if
they do this
now we go Rook H4 yeah
you have to be careful you cannot take
the queen or maybe you could but I don't
know I wouldn't want to to give white
some chances here to grab some pieces
for the queen and then still deal with
my weak King I would rather just make
sure that
I don't allow any entrances let's not
forget this King was not was it was safe
right now but if um oh it was in Tunisia
I'm sorry I'm sorry my bad
um Rook here and then King here and
something like that
makes a lot of sense right so we're not
we're not in a huge rush the queen is
attacked too so obviously you can't take
the bishop all right so King F1 Knight
C5 go away Queen
Rook H3
and now he played the same idea Rook H4
very nice defending of The Rook with the
queen so if you're going to trade we
take back we good
that's being attacked obviously the
queen was attacked from before and we
also have ideas like this
so Queen F3
and now this Rook from C8 is opening up
a little bit
um take stakes and now takes Queen takes
and let's see if you guys can find the
final of this game check out this King
coming towards the center you cannot go
back where it is safe now because the
Rooks were traded this is just a check
by the way we can go up so we have
some ideas here to take advantage of
basically white never took this Rook out
this night like I told you to look
beautiful but it did nothing and then
somehow he ended up with the Knight here
which is actually
totally trapped so let's see if we can
find a way to trap that Knight
more aggressive guys don't forget
there's a threat here too oops
there are a couple of threads for white
so we need to make forcing moves
yeah so just take the knife
take take and then
he did not take this night because as I
told you previously it was trapped he
thought he probably he could take it
anytime so he played Queen F4 and his
opponent resigned
um this this rule comes in this bishop
comes to G3 and that King is gonna get
mated shortly he preferred to do this
than to than to take the Knight if you
take the Knight I think you still have
to fight here for a little bit of time
not much obviously should still be
winning you have
um oh only one extra Pawn but well maybe
you're not winning anymore actually
because when you take that he takes here
he's getting some ideas you know he's
getting some counter play but if you do
this on the other hand
that King is super bad and you have a
check with white
that's it
no more checks well I guess fine we'll
give one more check
no more checks I can even play a five
let's just play F5 I like this move more
let's
finish it with a with the pawn move
and the skin turns out in the center and
game over
did you guys like this game
good because this is a beautiful idea
that actually so basically how I came
about to show you this game I was having
a talk with uh with Grandmaster Elsa
moradia body earlier today and I was I
was telling him that you know I I have I
want to do something about Fisher today
because you know it's the he it would
have been his 80th birthday and then we
talked about you know different games
and then he told me this game and I was
like oh my God this idea with H5 I
didn't know it so brilliant I love that
he's like really okay then I have
another idea for you and we went from
talking about Fisher to another game so
now I got another game that I'll show
you unfortunately it's not Fisher but I
definitely wanted to share with him for
this
day like I said so let's see this other
game where a similar idea was employed
by white this idea with F4 F5 a little
bit too soon in the naidorf and things
kind of went sideways let's check it out
so this is a game that was played
between portishe sorry airmenkov against
portishe and this was played in 1980
okay so this is this is 13 years later
compared to Fisher's game
so airmenkov started with E4
C5
Knight F3 D6
D4 C takes D4 Knight takes D4 Knight F6
Knight C3 A6 so we still have the Knight
ORF
um elshon likes sportish uh I think he
likes Fisher more I think everyone likes
Fisher well
chest wise
it is an idorph it's another night or
yes
um somehow I keep showing these neither
so I think it's a sign that I should
start studying naidorf like seriously or
maybe play it myself who knows who knows
maybe this is this is a time that I'm
just giving like I'm just having like
this hint here
um and uh
anyways we'll see so A6
Bishop C4 welcome
and now E6
A3
okay now in the other game we saw what
is the bishop E3 right
in this game A3 so airmenkov plays this
move for like similar reasons to retreat
with this bishop because in some
situations that Bishop is hanging with
the queen here or like I said this
tactical idea
so A3 is a is a way of recharging that
Bishop in A2 so Bishop E7 Bishop A2
um maybe this specific line for white is
not as topical these days not so many
top players you know still employed but
the Knight of is and then I think the
idea is quite similar and hopefully cool
so Castle
F4 once again all right
B5 F5 all right what do we do now you
already know from the from the previous
game okay some people in the audience
left but
it's fine do you remember what was the
idea
who
black doesn't
he doesn't want to push here right
because
he doesn't but in the other game did he
I think the other game you can push the
the H Pawn no yes yes so this is a
little bit different so now after Bishop
A2 in this game so fisher Fisher in the
other game he ended up
he ended up
um he ended up going B5 Bishop B7 here
and then when white brought in the pawn
forward he pushed E5 and then
yes the the bishop wasn't on B7 in this
game so so this this was a little bit
different it's not exactly the same so
it's the same uh idea that white
utilizes with pushing that F Pawn but
black changes a little bit so I'm trying
to show you the different
um the different ideas that are
that you have to
know when in the southern Sicilian for
black
so Bishop A2
now it's Castle right so before the
bishop was in B3 and there was B5 Bishop
B7 and this one was back but now white
wasted kind of an extra time with A3 and
he hasn't played F4 yet so because of
that white uh black one for the short
Castle instead
in the other game with the bishop E3
you aren't here but yeah
no I already showed this game yeah
yeah
so F4 B5 F5 V5 this is the game we're
looking at right now so E5 was played
and this is fine we're not worried it's
fine yes so after all the night dorf
oftentimes depending on what white plays
you want to play here well not always
but
unless they play Bishop G5 or Bishop C4
you want to play that move so in a way
it just seems like white is just helping
you to get that pawn there
if it makes sense
so
here I'm back development Knight G3
Queen B6 where
I know Queen these three
I think if you go for ideas like that
then probably I will just bring my queen
to defend and you're actually helping me
to get the queen there most likely I
don't know where I would put it here
here
and then I'll chase you back so I I
don't think that's helpful
for you
what do you want to do next
um I think you're not quite ready to
attack the skin yet and he can only
strike consider maybe long Castle but
here I mean if you if you play H5 now
you're weakening your king too much and
if
yeah yeah
and then and then if you go back then
I'll go Bishop E3 and then I can castle
and I already gain a few moves
um
yeah no
no so that's why I like Bishop B7
putting pressure on ig3 so we we have
seen these kind of ideas in the previous
game too but in that one black went for
H5
and then he had that idea but now we
can't do that so we gotta develop our
pieces 97 a typical idea someone tried
earlier to suggest it in the previous
game which was D5
but
um
but but you're not ready we're you're
not ready to push D5 just yet so you're
preparing it a little bit so Bishop here
Rook C8
Castle let's go I showed this idea
earlier
sir were you paying attention to what I
said about Rook C8
what did I say
sometimes you will sacrifice sometimes
you can sacrifice that so I tricked you
about the other game that it was going
to be a sacrifice you're probably
wondering what is she talking about
there's no second there's no sacrifice
in this game
well that's an idea and it's a very
renowned idea I think a lot of people
should know it even if you don't play
the Sicilian you should know this idea
that must have been some tactics you've
done at some point so here portishe went
for this Rook sack
sorry exchange sack
um and typically what ends up happening
after you sacrifice there then you end
up just taking this Pawn so you can take
it with a knight or with a bishop it's
quite clear that you're going to take
with the Knight is it clear for both of
you here
you want to keep the bishop you want it
open and
um
and that square can be utilized by the
other night later
and there's this terminology that a lot
of people like to use is this very fancy
word that's I think it's called
Superfluous Square when you have too
many pieces that you want to put on that
same square and you can't but this way
if you trade the Knight then this other
one can go to F6 otherwise you couldn't
just have two pieces stay there it's not
that kind of a fancy square like they
would usually use the term but I still
think that you we could use it to
understand that we want to use it for
this other night
so Knight takes E4
Bishop takes E4 takes takes
so what do we have here so we sacrificed
an exchange and we got a pawn but we
also have these two Central pawns that
could push forward and we have a
destroyed Pawn structure in White's um
White's camp and
their ideas with this Rook coming this
way
um and the Knight will go to F6
definitely to keep the king safe and
then supports the push of these Central
pawns it's kind of nice that we stayed
with the live Square bishop and we have
the pawns on dark for the moment
uh C4
white is trying to get rid of their
double Pawns
what do we do should we take in C4
Rook C8 of course never don't help your
opponent let him take obviously he's
going to get rid of his double Pawn
which is weak but you know we won't we
won't
um
take ourselves to help you get the
bishop out put pressure and things like
that so improving the position of our
Rook Queen E2
Knight F6 we don't want to retreat with
this bishop just yet because it does
quite a good job of keeping pressure
over a lot of squares
and now Rook a
I didn't Rook a to C1 to keep the phone
protected
we couldn't do this because of this in
between move
okay
what is a good plan for black in this
position
we still cannot take it C4
but Queen B7 or queen A7 Queen E7 is
just I'm sorry D here yeah
you want to put pressure there okay or
check one between four
four
sliding in
wait if you do this and I do that you
want to do what queen yeah
I know I know I'm hanging the pawn but
um
my Bishop will come into play I'm not so
worried about that
um I know you're getting D5 in I'm just
trying to figure out if if your
yeah now the material is technically
equal but I feel that I could come on
the B file I could be wrong totally
wrong these are always tough to play
okay I'll go Rook B2 first Maybe
maybe oh but then I give this Pawn okay
okay
yeah this is kind of maybe I shouldn't
trade Queens
let's go back
okay so if I went to H1 what did you
want to do next I was thinking just put
the queen closer to the front board like
Queen before but it does kind of just
harassment but yeah
but then this is gonna be kind of weak
as well
um I also feel that could I play here or
would you
for sure needs uh needs some checking
okay maybe okay now that I protected
that Bondo could I take
it is it
why
oh you can take
well you have history you want to take
and then you want to take in C2 or
something I guess
I know but you did give up a pawn so I
mean
you will just get it back right I mean
right now you have just an exchange
you don't have a palm for the exchange
I mean you do have this kind of idea I
don't know how good it is
no not me now
no I I'll take here too I mean your
pawns are not Advanced enough to really
be so worried I think it maybe it was an
option I mean we can see we can see what
it says it says it would have been a
good option
Queen A7 as well
it is natural yeah I agree and besides
like you need to improve the queen I
totally agree he came up with a
different kind of idea first before
getting his Queen he thought he would
create some weakness maybe a little bit
on the king side so he went for H5 which
is a cool kind of idea I think so you're
creating your Luft just in case for the
background to be safe and then you also
have you know you can support this kind
of attack on the King right later
potentially
so he gave it up
attracted white to take that pawn so now
when he play Queen A7
uh he could yeah but he didn't he still
didn't that's what I like about the game
he just went for H4 because now this
bishop is so strong and the King got
restricted so I think he was mostly
interested in winning this game maybe
tactically attacking chess rather than
positionally which what you're
suggesting seemed quite good actually
too
so he wants H3 and he just wants to
finish the game fast Queen B3 was played
and now the Knight came in
to follow that idea
yeah
so now H3
all right what do we do
where do we move the Knight
e
e yes very good yes Knight E let's go
let's go
crazy you want to sacrifice but but you
do know you do know he's got something
right
yeah no you will get mated here like if
you go night there and you or you want
Bishop G2 something but no you know you
don't need to you don't need yours or
you're already sacrificing exchange you
can go and you know and this is a this
is a hole that white has created in the
position by pushing H3 so if you take
there you can go to a G3 which is going
to be brilliant and that happened Rook
there to protect G2 what else Knight
except five
not to come in with check and now it's
time for black to start pushing his his
Central pawns this also blocks these two
pieces
white tried the last resource and try to
break open that diagonal and then you
know if you push to go here or something
create something out of nothing
how do you think Portage continued in
this position
so what's the word whites sorry what's
Black's worst place piece
The Rook can be improved the queen can
go to F2 as well yes that's a nice idea
as well
the bishop is great you don't like this
no but I started with white and then I
corrected myself black black
this Rook can be improved so you want
Rook B8
I was thinking
he played it the next move
but do you want to try to mate with
Queen G3 and stuff
I thought maybe
Queen F2 and
Knight G3 Knight G8 Knight E2 and then
eight it doesn't work so I'm used
ridiculous okay okay
he he did go Queen F2 so first chase the
the queen away from there and now when
Queen F2 is played you have your
Tactical ideas maybe some kind of mates
over on the king but then you also have
Rook B2 and obviously that Bishop is
hanging too so why try the final thing
to grab some material
but now Rook B2
bringing the final piece into the game
took and now let's see if you guys can
find the final the finish of this
beautiful game
can you make it more forcing
more forcing Queen check
s
Queen wear
though it's just
take too much
I didn't I did not say it's made I said
more forcing
country
Queen G3 is being said
King H1
Rook uh Knight to H4 nope
nope
I I this is what you're saying and then
here
um
what is your threat exactly here if I
I mean
push or something or maybe I check you
first and then
yeah it doesn't work I mean it could be
another waning idea I guess you want to
take in G2 so I'll take there probably
and then
you'll take it that night probably and
then with the bishop so that you take a
return but the thing is if I go here
then you have to take with the bishop
so then you will get that position
I guess we could try this line for a
while to try to escape here and then
it's insane hmm
no I mean I know I know it's hanging I
just want to do this and I feel like I
could save myself here so probably you
should play here but then I get the
bishop out and you have to still try to
to win this it will take you some time
it should be winning it should be nice
oh wait wait wait wait no there
not so easy
you're giving him some chances
is
yeah so Queen takes G2 Queen takes G2 it
was the move that he played Bishop tg2 I
feel that it possibly work so Queen
takes G2 yes yes takes check nig3 and
and white resigned obviously he can
still go for this but you know you're
gonna lose pretty much everything it's
not made but it's kind of like it would
be because you can take yeah so that was
the that was the finish of this game
yeah yeah so I I try to kind of combine
them like you know I thought it was cool
I actually have two other games but I
guess that will have to stay for next
week
um so once again what did we do today or
trying to
um
how when you're going to study an
opening my whole point was when you're
going to study an opening go back look
at some classical game see what ideas
were present then even if those ideas
um you know might not be
played officially in like by strong
players I think they're still relevant
because ideas remain ideas are you know
quite big and we saw this really cool
h-pawn push idea exchange sacrifice
capturing E4
quite a lot of
cool themes for black and you also
learned that in the night or if you can
sometimes leave the king in the center
and it's going to be totally fine so
maybe some ideas don't some of these
ideas don't work today that's true but
um I think if you don't know these you
don't understand why the ones that work
today
are
that good possibly I think so anyways I
hope you guys liked
this class
um do you guys have any questions anyone
before we sign off tonight
all right well I just wanted to say
goodbye to everyone in the chat uh don't
forget I need to make an announcement
that
um starting March 12th all the way till
March 16th there's going to be the San
Luis super Swiss
I will be doing commentary for that
event if anyone is interested in taking
part in it in it they're still looking
for foreign players so all you have to
do is send an email to Mike cummer and
then
um they'll get to you they'll get you
ready to play in the tournament and I
believe it's um free entry for everyone
so why wouldn't you have why wouldn't
you want to play
um well
as for me I will be seeing you next I
believe on Saturday for some Simon so
stay tuned for everything on sandwiches
club's website
have a wonderful night everyone
[Music]